so 55 years since this has been going on
I don't mean to sound impudent but is
this the longest relationship in your
life not quiet I have a relationship
with an English football team which
started when I was seven have they
broken your heart
yes constant well see so that prepares
you for filmmaking right
no causes brutal in the course of making
this you had to have felt over the years
and perhaps all at the same time like a
friend a confessor a provocateur as well
as a filmmaker yes a father figure or
someone they can take take it take their
bad feelings on that was the
relationship sustained over the seven
years in between each no I really left
it alone between them you know I didn't
want to be shadowing their lives I
didn't want them to be thinking that
they have to put on a performance for me
and so even if lots of interesting
things happened in a seventh year if it
didn't kind of fit into what was clearly
going on then I would wouldn't touch it
otherwise these films would you be here
for three weeks watching it did they
reach out to you at all or did they try
to get about with their lives and in
those seven years in between such a
magical number seven um no but there we
kind of check out with them you know
once a year just to make sure all is
well or they too will tell us if things
aren't well you know things that would
affect the work we're gonna do so but I
I just didn't want to be in their lives
all the time well I wanted to be in the
audience's point of view to see them my
god they've changed of all that kind of
stuff or as if I had a close
relationship with them
this was the ninth in the series I
hadn't seen the earlier ones but just
watching this one I felt so emotionally
invested in who they were and how their
lives had changed that I can imagine
that's only a fraction of how you felt
no but I mean IIIi think we're we sort
of got it right it's got a good balance
to it you know it's it's because it's so
much material it's a ludicrous and
that's when there we only film them you
know every seventh year so you know you
want to keep keep it Swift and and you
know not to fill the film up with stuff
that you couldn't possibly follow you
know that everything has to be kind of
fixed on the seventh seventh year well
now obviously there's things that were I
cheated on like when Bruce got married
we're going to shoot that or something
like that
but I try and keep it as honorable as I
can to the seventh year otherwise I'd
have so much material I'd kill myself
this has been a glimpse of Britain's
future was it really because Britain is
so different nowadays when it seems to
come to class and race and yeah I think
so so their lives are different than
mine was when I was growing up you know
the England has changed you know
dramatically and we we kind of
fortunately got a nice period with it
you know there was huge change
you can hardly believe what England was
like and when that when we started you
know in whatever that was 1964 it was a
different world not necessarily a worse
world or necessarily a better word now
but it's it has changed at all I was
thinking how immensely different it
would look if you were to start now with
the racial composition the
number of men versus women boys versus
girls well I mean I got caught out with
some of that I mean the big thing that
was not a disaster for me god forbid but
you know women came coming into society
of roaring and you know why we sort of
wouldn't miss it but it happened so
quickly when do you think of the 14
people we chose only four were women I
mean you know you wouldn't like that
would you if you said there so there's
you know there was it was run by men
well well it was but it's once your once
I said get the thing in motion there's
no way out of it I mean I cheated you
know I used the wives of some of the
boys who were very interesting well over
the course of all of this while you were
doing is you were doing all of your
films you were doing television you've
done ray Donovan you've done masters of
sex so talk a little bit about moving
from each of those media from
documentaries to feature films to
television and you know how that works
in your life and why you sought that
balance well that's how my life in
business started you know I went into
Granada television who were a terrific
place to be you know you know there's
this is there though their work and all
that so there was a lot of opportunity
and then Granada was a very red-hot
place you know that the BBC had been
running the world has it were released
the British world and making a bit of a
mess of it and looking making all
Victorian and all that and then Granada
came in and farted all over the place
and really changed you know a word BBC
would never use of course and of course
the laws they would even know what I was
told
but they're great people and of course
they pulled themselves together really
quickly to resume their place at the top
of the top of the world but no but
really they were asleep and then Granada
came along and woke them up and I was
part of the waking up of the BBC it
sounds silly but it was so you know that
that's how it happened Michael Apted
we'll see you in seven years yeah
won't you please thank you
[Applause]